okay so let's talk about heterodox
Academy because you set that up this
organization that you should tell
everybody about in in precisely to deal
with this issue and so I'd like I'd like
to know about it
oh it's growing what it's doing what
your aims are all of that so I gave this
talk in 2011 laying out the fact that we
have no more conservatives in social
psychology and why this makes it hard
for us to find truth and in the months
after that a few social psychologists
resonated with the message they said wow
I think that I think you're right I have
some data on this so the five of us were
six of us wrote this paper it came out
and behavioral and brain sciences oh
sure a lot of stir and I'm sorry was the
sixth one that I forgot to add in before
we got this paper published in
behavioral brain sciences it came out it
was sort of online in 2014 but it came
out for good in the summer 2015 which
coincidentally was the same summer that
my article came out with Greg lukianov
called the coddling of the American mind
that was about things going on with
undergrads but our concern was entirely
faculty was just the nature of the
academic community the research
community so we got these two things
going on summer 2015 and then that
summer I hear from Nick Rosencrantz a
law professor who says we have the same
problem in law but he was worse in law
well it's really bad in Canada law okay
because and as he points out we're
training all these students they never
meet a conservative then they have to go
argue cases in front of judges half of
whom were appointed by Republicans they
have no idea what a conservative thinks
this is malpractice we got a train
so say and I hear from a sociologist
Chris Martin same thing in sociology so
the three of us said hey you know this
is a have you looked at faculties of
Education oh my god those are the worst
by worse I don't know the numbers but in
terms of the vindictiveness that the
Incred the pressure put on any
non-conforming opinion my impression I
don't have data but my impression from
the letters I get is that education
schools and Social Work schools yeah are
the worst that's exactly in keeping with
my my understanding as well it's hard to
tell which of those two are worst I
would say it's the faculties of
Education because they have a direct
pipeline to kids in terms of their
effect yes farmer pernicious yeah yes
yeah but
but equally equally warped let's say but
but more pernicious and and the things
that are happening in the Canadian
education system as a consequence of
that are so reprehensible if we should
today because it's happening here too
with these ideas filtering down to high
school I've been so focused on college
now we're discovering the problem is
actually baked in the illiberal
attitudes are often baked in yes and
purposefully like in in Canada
increasingly the the radical leftists
have control over curriculum development
and they're starting to develop social
justice curriculums which is what they
call them for kindergarten kids so it's
literally well it's been something
they'll get back to the earlier grades
so so regionally three of us decided to
put up a website I invited all the other
authors from the the BBS paper we
invited a few other people working on
this and so for the first year we had
this project was called heterodox
Academy org we put the site up on about
September 10th I think it was 2015 and
it was just a community of researchers
who are studying the problem of the lack
of viewpoint diversity well five days
later the protests start at Missouri so
these are racially motivated protests or
protests about racial insensitivity and
racial problems at Missouri and at first
it seemed like this is just a Missouri
prom but coming in the wake of course of
Ferguson and all the videos we saw of
unarmed black men being killed by police
the a lot of these concerns spread to
other universities the protests aren't
just about race but it was that fall of
especially the Yale protests when the
president of Yale validates their
narrative that Yale's are racist place
we have to reform Yale then it spreads
nationally and now suddenly this is not
just a faculty issue anymore so even
though it had rocks the Academy will
mostly focus on the faculty we're now
seeing it's a complex ecosystem with all
kinds of forces acting on universities
so that between 2015 and 2017 the danger
of speaking honestly about what you
think about an academic or intellectual
proposition has skyrocketed the risk of
being mobbed ostracized formally
investigated by title 9 people for
example I'm people we're sitting here at
my you go to any bathroom I'll show you
on this floor go to any bathroom
sign telling students exactly what
number to call to report you or me if we
say something that is that someone takes
to be Elias act oh so you have bias you
have bias investigation teams here
that's right see we haven't got to that
point that particular point in Canada
yet so I think we're farther ahead down
that path in some ways but not quite as
far in others yeah that's really that's
really unbelievable so things are
changing very very fast it's not at all
schools but then again things are
changing so fast we don't really know we
don't have good data on what's going on
what I can tell you though is that at
heterodox Academy when we started out in
2015 there was a lot of suspicion a lot
of people on the Left were afraid like
oh is this some right-wing group now
very few of us are actually on the right
but because we end up mostly speaking up
for libertarians and conservatives who
are attacked or silenced you know people
will think oh we must be right-wing but
we're not I mean I'm I've never voted
for Republican in my life I've never
given money to a Republican campaign I'm
now increasingly calling myself a
liberal now that we see a liberalism
flourishing but so when we started out
there was a lot of suspicion of us from
many professors but now that it's clear
that the problems these are not just a
few anecdotes this is the new normal and
it's not just in the Universities as you
pointed out that's right it's
exhilarating
it's like mad and it's not just in the
u.s. it's spread when in 2015 I thought
it was uniquely American problem yeah
boy it's in Canada and the UK and it's
really what New Zealand that's right it
is a uniquely Anglosphere problem this
is really interesting it's not on the
continent very much at all what about in
the Nordic countries no I mean they have
so political correctness you have lots
of places the unique thing that
identifies this new culture is linking
the political correctness with the sense
of fragility and this is something
America's pioneered the idea that so in
Britain they've always had no
platforming they call it so if there's
and there was an absolute British
National Party's a natural fascist party
you know so if a if a BNP member is
gonna speak on campus you mob him you
shut it down
no Platt don't give a platform so you
know you've had passionate politics
certainly since the 60s so that's not
new and that's everywhere what's new is
the American I
yeah that if someone says something and
it could be a sincerely expressed idea
not a racist range just like well I
don't know I think that maybe hormones
do a fit gendered behavior can you say
that well what if someone takes that as
as somehow essentializing gender and
then saying that women are inferior or
whatever if they knows well that
happened to James d'amour for exactly
exactly so so that's what's new is the
idea that if someone says something that
someone a member of a protected or
marginalized group is offended by that
person is harmed if that person is
harmed
we must protect that person and more
ominously just in the last year or two
it's not just that they're harmed their
suffering is that this was vile yes
right violence yeah well that's part of
the postmodern narratives that and this
whole thing to policy is so dangerous
the the crossing the line into into
violence it just occurred to me just
like yesterday I was thinking about this
wait the state is supposed to have a
monopoly on violence right but if speech
especially his speech and her speech and
the people the speech of those people in
that academic movement or on the and
that if their speech is violence well
the state is supposed to have a monopoly
on their speech then and and if it's
violence well then we have a right to
use violence back the state does never
Napoli on our violence because our
violence is you know it's morally
motivated so just the Orwellian and
authoritarian implications of this move
once you say that speech is violence
you're unlocking you know you're opening
Pandora's box I mean you're five steps
down the road to hell and I'd say we're
about seven steps down okay you so
you're are you're that concerned about
it